welcome back to bringing the pain with
Gus and Wayne hi I'm your host Wayne I'm
Gus and I'm Tony Oh Wayne's cousin oh
yeah
and we're back in the studio with the
product I am tagged about Oh Chad Chad
chopped and ah yes ah this next product
paint approved by the FDA but that ain't
stopping us it's okay this spray was
created to defeat the haters so you know
me and Wayne had to get in on just hop
on the nozzle and spray the toxins repel
haters from your line of sight move it
and let's talk a light scent of lavender
when sprayed can you say yummy so it's
just like a scented pepper spray let's
take this baby out into the street to
see it in action let's go I am a dancer
are you trying to ruin my name oh my I
am so sorry it's just you guys were
skipping does he hate the way that we
skip no not at all you're skipping us
fine it's just like maybe tone it down
[Applause]
or are we fighting toxic masculinity
hashtag think about it
[Music]
beautiful human women be interested in
our little sprigs you just walk around
with cameras and people's faces
yummy is this do you make money this way
do your parents know I made orphan and
we have a bunch of skills okay no we
can't cuz we're doing yeah this is not a
blank check of bitchiness Gus is my wig
look good oh my god
Tanya does my look look at you I've
never looked good hold up are you saying
that we have to respect women even
though we don't have sex with them yes a
progressive Tonino still unsure Pater
Annihilator spray is for you well
luckily I invited two very special
guests to join us live here in the
studio and explain the spray more
in-depth oh my god Bret stain this is
Rex and ISA scientists that did our the
sciency stuff for the spray sciency
stuff this is a bit more to it than that
what's up and I am Mary
that's so Brixton and I are here to
explain the chemical compounds that were
can you shake it just like that last
Wednesday mean nothing to you that's
Wednesday we just had you said we had a
future you said he would name our first
child LeBron James Earl Jones you have
it let's pray that is simple to you
and effectiveness you're interested in
purchasing hater Annihilator go to our
website at www.mataharicourse.com since
[Music]